one of the most talked about shows this
year has been the netflix hit
bridgerton andy have you caught any of
bridgerton i have it's
it's really fun i mean it's not my
normal thing but it's fun
i was i thought i thought so too i
wasn't sure i was gonna like it i
started watching it and uh
it's just it's just a good time well uh
some big news
just came out about bridgeton uh reggae
jean page will not be reprising the role
of simon bassett
wow that he's like the breakout star of
that show that's a big deal
yeah yeah and he's not coming back wow
fans are
freaking out and uh it's all over the
internet
everybody's freaking out about it and
then i hear one of our writers
apparently has something he wants to say
about this i don't know what it is
but i should give him a chance to speak
so let's talk to him now please welcome
skyler higley skyler are you there oh
hey conan
skylar what are you wearing oh this
these are just my
regular clothes i wear every day but i
guess you're right
i do look like the perfect replacement
for rage on paige
no i i never said i don't think i said
it all that you should replace
reggae jean page well then why did i
tell everyone you did conan
i don't know why you told people that
don't tell people that
look skyler it's a huge role on a huge
show do you have any kind of acting
experience at all
yes conan i already have about what 15
seconds of on-screen experience
and i'm already killing it i wouldn't
say you're killing it
you're just chatting with me uh look
this is a demanding role that requires
serious acting skills
can you even do a british accent of
course check this out oi
blimey govna it's me simon bassett
mayor of bridgerton here to fornicate
with you
no one says i want to fornicate with you
no one would ever say i'm here to
fornicate with you
make sweet love no no no
open your nickname no no not in up in
anyone's knickers that was terrible
i don't know cohen it sounds like you're
jealous you know when i do this accent
people say i sound like the british
idris elba
so idris elba is british
okay conan by the way i took the lorry
to my flat where i ate some fish and
chips and did some
colonizing oh yeah okay yeah that's what
people say i'm gonna go do some
colonizing skyler
even if they looked past your horrible
british accent i have to tell you this
is a very highly sexualized role
i get that and i think i'm mature enough
to work around boobies
so spoken like a real authorial yeah
look
ray gage on page is a heartthrob women
love this guy
yeah yeah i get it he's handsome but you
know maybe the character could be funny
i could
make everyone horny with humor okay and
how would you do that
oh easy check this out
let's have sex okay no one's going to
like that
actually i'm kind of turned down by that
all right look
skyler you're a very funny writer
terrific writer but you're not gonna
replace
reggae jean-page it's not gonna happen
well
i guess there's only one thing to say to
that conan
[Music]
you've crushed my dreams
and that means you okay hey
the hell was that all right
yes you've got the part clearly because
you're so sexy and the slide whistle is
just driving women nuts
wow nothing says reggae jean page like
that sound